the families of sheikh had been given a
month to consider a compromise deal on
their fate on tuesday they returned
their decision
we rejected the proposal by the israeli
supreme court which would have rendered
us protected tenants at the mercy of
settler organizations we stand firm in
our refusal to compromise on our rights
the homes were awarded to palestinian
refugee families under jordanian rule in
the 1950s but a jewish settle
organization claims it has ownership
rights over the land a claim endorsed by
israeli court rulings
rather than issue a final verdict the
supreme court had wanted the families to
accept protected tenancy status for up
to three generations while they
continued to make their own ownership
case
some saw it as worthy at least of
consideration but the final decision is
to fight on in a case that's become
emblematic of the palestinian struggle
we hope that everyone who supported us
from the beginning will keep doing so so
that we don't end up on the street if
the court rules that we will be evicted
for several weeks in april and may this
year it felt as though the small
neighborhood was the epicenter of the
palestinian-israeli conflict the case
was one of the triggers for the round of
hamas rocket fire that marked the start
of this year's gaza war legal experts
say that the fact that the court was
pushing this deal so hard is a signal
that it's aware that a final verdict is
likely to go against the palestinian
families and such a final decision is
one that would come with huge political
sensitivity
the question now if such a verdict comes
down will it be enforced by an israeli
government under significant u.s
pressure to leave the families in their
homes
inevitably
there will be a coalition crisis there
will be a change in government or there
will be a terror attack
um with uh double-digit casualties in
which the bloodlust of certain elements
in israeli society will soar
and they will be evicted
israel's legal and political
establishment had been keen to turn the
temperature down in sheikh jura at least
for a while instead it may be about to
start heating up again harry fawcett al
jazeera occupied east jerusalem